[موسيقى]
اهلا هذا فنجان من ثمانيه وانا عبد الرحمن
ابو مالح هذه الحلقه رقم 276 بعد اكثر من
سبع سنوات واكثر من 150 مليون استماع
تعلمت كثير ولكن في مشكله حسيتها صارت في
فنجان في الاشهر الماضيه حسيت اني
ضعت عن الهدف الاساسي
اتوقع ان التعليقات اثرت فيني بدون ما
ادري يمكن علشان كده اخذت استراحه محارب
في الاسابيع الماضيه ووقفت فنجان رغم انه
التعليقات وانكات على فنجان ما تزعجني
واحيانا انبسطت عليهم اشاركها مع اهلي
واصدقائي واحيانا تويتر
اتذكر اول ايميل الي في عام كان في عام
2000 كنت بزر وقتها لكني
خلقت في الجينات يحب الانترنت ومن ذاك
الوقت حتى الان عشت في الانترنت معظم
حياتي واقدر اقول اني وصلت الى فكره ايش
يعني محتوى انترنت
لا يشبه اي وسيط او منصه ثانيه الناس
عندها النمط مع تقبل الجديد الانترنت نفسه
تلقى وقتها اللي يقال عنهم النخبه يبينونه
الانترنت مجرد شيء ماله قيمه تذكر ولو
بعد ما فرض الانترنت نفسك جزء من حياه
الناس وبدات طبقات تتغير تلقى الناس تحرمه
وتحاربه وتحاول سن اي قوانين وعقبات في
طريق انتشاره او في طريق منع هذه التقلبات
لكنها قاعده ربانيه اما ما ينفع الناس
فيمكث في الارض فالشيء صح يبقى وعلى ذلك
تقدر تشوف هذا النمط مع اي تقنيه جديده
ولان اليوم سالفه التقنيه سالفته هي
المحتوى اقدر اضع مقاييس او مقياس موازي
للي شرحته قبل شوي على الاحترام المحتوى
الانترنت لا يشبه اي محتوى ثاني خارج
المحتوى الانترنت ومحتوي يشبه صاحبه محتوى
يشبه الناس اللي تابعه كان زمان على
التلفزيون فيه واحد يختار معيار المحتوى
معيار المقدد ومعيار اللغه ومعيار ومقدار
ويختار كرفته او نوع شماغ المقدم يختار
توجه للقناه وما يستحق الناس ان يسمعوا
وما لا يجب ان لا يسمعه همم يعتقد انه
يفهم اكثر مننا وهذا الزمان انتهى نقطه
الحين بتقدر تكتب مقالات من ثلاث كلمات او
10 الاف كلمات تقدر تكتبها بالعامي او
الفصيح اتذكر قبل كم سنه كنا ننشر في
ثمانيه المقالات بطريقه عناوين شوفها
مناسبه وجاني
رئيس تحرير لصحيفه تقليديه جاني عيونه
الطاير غضبا يقول كيف تكتبون العناوين كذا
لو شافوها الصحفيين المصريين بالتريقه
ولا اهتميت له ولا الصحفيين في مصر وغيرها
اذا هو يشوفها صح يكتبها طريقه والناس
اليوم عندها قدره الاختيار ايش علاقه هذا
كله من فنجان اعتقد واضحه
البودكاست بيغض النظر هو مكان يجب يجب ان
يكون عفوي والعفويه مو انك تنزل الشماغ
وتتكلم عمي لا اليوم كل قناه
اخباريه في الجزيره العربيه عندها اكثر من
برنامج تلفزيوني في منصه فانا اقول انه
برنامج تليفزيوني لانه مو بوبكاست رغم انه
في البوتاسكاست فلا يمكن لاي بوت كاس يكون
في التلفزيون ولا يمكن لاي برنامج
تليفزيوني يكون في البوتجاز البودكاست
والانترنتي تقدر تشوف نفسك فيه تدري انك
تقدر تسوي مثلها واحسن لو بغيت وكل ما
تحتاجه انك تطلع جوالك وتسجل فيه او تشتري
ادوات قيمه 3 ريال
زي ما تبي كثير من المثقفين العرب اليوم
فقدوا مكانهم في الانترنت وحافظوا عليك
اماكنهم السابقه مثل التليفزيون
ولكن ما عاد احد يتابعها ولا يقدرون
ينزلون من ابراجيه الى الناس
الجمعيات الثقافيه اللي ما يحضرها احد
الناس اليوم ابحث عن الثقافه عن التطوير
وطور نفسها ومجتمعها واعطانها في كل
المجالات لكن باسلوبهم اليوم في فنجان
تلقى حلقه عن تاريخ اليهود في الحضاره
الغربيه وصلت الى اكثر من مليون استماع
مشاهده موضوع اكثر من كده دقه واكثر من
كده ثقافه ما في
وتلقى حلقه عن الاقتصاد برده باكثر من
مليون اجتماعي مشاهده عن السياسه واللغه
والجغرافيا والبيئه والتقنيه حلقات
مليونيه في تخصصات علميه دقيقه وهذا ليس
حكرا على فنجان فهذا التوجه العام في كل
المحتوى الانترنت السعوديه وعربيا وعالميه
الناس تسمع محتوها باسلوب يشبه
الشباب في الانترنت
نفسه جزء من حياه الناس وغير الطبقات
الثقافيه النبويه وقلبها راسا على عقب انا
هنا ما دافع عن فنجان ولا عني فاخطائي
كثيره ولكل ااا نصيب من النقص لكن هي
اعتبرها ملاحظه لاحطها في مشهد المحتوى
الانترنت
والاسبوع الجاي حلقه جديده بحول الله
الحلقات ممكن تتغير كليا
وممكن ما احد يلاحق باي تغيير بس اكيد اني
بكون مبسوط وانا اسجلها وانا انبسط
بالحلقات اللي تقدم محتوى جديد
وتكون في طابع نقاش لطيف كنت يوم بديت
اعمل اني اسوي محتوى احبه ويكون فيه الف
واحد يحب الحمد لله اليوم عشرات الملايين
يحبونا وهذا فضل من الله عز وجل عليه
الاسبوع المقبل
[موسيقى]